and even though we just ended one round
of playoffs and have a long way to go
until the next regular season begins
we're going to play a way to early
edition of what's more likely with
odds provided as always by our friends
at points bet
the division odds the likelihood
or otherwise of a team to win in its
four-team
configuration let's begin with this
what's more likely
the chiefs win the afc west again
or the buccaneers win the nfc south the
buccaneers did not
win the nfc south this year the odds for
2021
kansas city minus 400 that means you got
to bet 400 to win 100
and the the tampa bay buccaneers are
minus 140
to win the nfc south bet 140 to win 100.
what's more likely i think that
i would go with still the chiefs winning
the afc west and
and again the buccaneers i expect them
to be really good it's just the fact
that
hey the new orleans saints are still
there and i don't really care if drew
brees is there or not they win without
him
very well i mean a lot a lot of it so
i'm not
that's where i think there is we're in
the afc west yes
the raiders are you know getting better
we see the chargers with urber
and you know the broncos showed some
encouraging signs too but there's
nothing i can latch on there
yet to go oh i think they can overtake
the chiefs
in the west i don't see that so i'm
going to go with the bucks what about
you all right
i'm going with the chiefs who the hell
is urber
herbert yeah justin you left you left
some letters off but that's okay they
i'm going to say the buccaneers okay
because
i don't see a contender now look the
saints are always going to be the saints
i don't want to get any
any hostile text messages from anyone
who's going to suggest to me that i'm
not properly giving the saints their
respect and chris you know who we get
those text messages from
but but without drew brees i got i got
to see it to believe it
so right now going to the season i would
say the chiefs coming off of what
happened
this year you know a little shine a
little shine off the the helmet sure
and and here are the bucks they're
they're parading around their
their trophy yeah and uh i just i don't
think any of the other teams are gonna
be ready to come up and take
that that division title from them that
they didn't win this show i know
they won the better prize that's great
yeah it's they're it's an interesting
division
you know all together too because
atlanta does have some talent there too
you know we saw that be a little bit of
a pain in the butt for tampa bay this
year and carolina too
it's a tough one you know both teams are
extremely talented
and you know again let's not forget i
know the luster has worn off the chiefs
a little bit
but you know best right tackle in
football
first round pick at left tackle other
lineman hurt
you know they're they're a different
team when they got that up there too
certainly and my home's healthy to go
along with it but i i hear that's a
toss-up question both teams are so damn
good
well and look the chiefs fire will be
reignited
for 2021 patrick mahomes an intense
competitor and he's going to want to get
back there and win it next year
uh to make up for what happened this
past season that's for sure all right
let's move on what's more likely the
steelers
to repeat as the afc north champs or the
titans
to repeat as the afc south champs
the odds aren't in here pete do we have
the odds there are the odds baltimore
is the plus 110 favorite
although no one's in negative territory
there the steelers all the way down at
plus 280 which tells you where they are
cincinnati well
i i'll tell you what plus 2300
i'd i i put a sawbuck on the bengals
those odds are i think those are too
long i think the bengals have a chance
to make something happen next year
there are the titans at minus 115 and uh
with the the texans and
i'd have the texans below the jaguars at
this point wouldn't you
look at that jaguars at plus 1600 in
houston at plus a thousand
houston's in disarray they're one of the
most dysfunctional teams in football
right now and we don't know they're
gonna have desean watson no i know i
think
i'd probably have at least equal to
jacksonville as far as you know at the
plus 1600 thing there
oh all together i mean what are you
gonna go with go ahead i want you to go
first here steelers repeat his afc north
champs are tight
titans this is easy yeah it is easy
tight right i mean the afc north is too
damn good
i mean we see i mean yeah the steelers
won the afc north you know what would he
do
whoopity-doo okay because i think the
ravens
were a better football team as a whole
and i i think cleveland was
right there very much equal to that as
well so yeah i'm with you
the titans we got to worry about the
cults it's really one team
you know there's there's and like you
said in the ufc north that bottom team
with joe burrow in cincinnati there's
some talent there there's something to
build on
to where they're not going to be a
pushover next year either i don't think
i agree with you there
and one thing that we learn every year
now we're back into the off-season mode
where we assume for the purposes of all
debates arguments and takes that
everyone's going to be healthy all year
long
the great wild card that screws up
everything
is the reality that guys are going to
get injured
and that changes things so i mean we saw
it two years ago with ben roethlisberger
gone in week two with the elbow injury
and
and i still am not a hundred percent
convinced
that the steelers and roethlisberger are
gonna work out
their contractual stuff yeah ed
bouchette had something last week on the
athletic
about it i've been meaning to write
about it what do you say it intrigues me
just
it's just because the two sides say
they're willing it's
you got to work it out it's still got to
be done right
i mean we assume that all the steelers
want to do is take the money that roths
burgers do to make and convert it to a
bonus and spread out the cap dollars
but what if they want to pay him less i
mean he said i don't care what i make
well what's that mean you're going to
make the minimum
i mean yeah some of these guys i want to
just go
wide to do it who cares i mean you got
so much money
i i'm just speaking to me i really think
in my my
my own self if i was ben roethlisberger
with the way the team is how close
i'm in the end of the tunnel i'd almost
do it like with drew brees i'd go
sign me to a million dollar contract
i'll play for peanuts this year i don't
give a damn let's make the team good
let's make one more big run
i got enough money in the bank let's go
like that's what i would do
i'm just not a big fan i know of making
it known to the world that
it's one more year and i'm scarred by
what happened with brett favre in
minnesota
now with jerome bettis and that's the
most immediate
and easy comparison for ben
roethlisberger they got close in 2004
so in 2005 one more run one more go with
jerome bettis and they won a super bowl
and
bettis walked off into the sunset and
i'm sure that roethlisberger would like
to try to do that
the problem is if it goes sideways in
september and october he's going to
regret
i mean i don't think this team is so
close
that you say uh just come back for one
more year and it'll be
it'll be fine i i think that there's a
huge gap
right now i i don't want to say huge
there's a gap
between the steelers and the chiefs the
steelers and the bills
they'd have to have a lot of stuff fall
their way to end up in the super bowl
and win it
in 2021 yeah there's definitely some i
mean we talk i mean there's
some reconstruction that needs to be
done with the steelers
on the offensive side of the ball the
offensive line we've talked about that
the approach on offense all together
you know running back all they got they
got issues there's no doubt
not good like not to where you go oh
concerning issues
you're right i still look at them and go
it's a playoff team
but i think there's parts that certainly
need to be improved
so that we start thinking about them as
a super bowl caliber team which is what
we didn't think of them
you know after that first loss to
washington and we went from there we
just every week we started to go
it just doesn't look right doesn't look
good there's issues and they got to fix
those
uh what's more likely the bills don't
win the afc
east or the jets don't finish last
in the afc east the bills uh obviously
the favorites at minus 170
the jets the long shot at plus 1600 so
do you have bills not at number one or
jets not at number four
well i i feel like sitting here you know
mid february
gosh i i just i think i gotta go with
i think the jets are gonna finish last i
do i don't think they're ready to climb
out of that yet so
i'll go with the bills don't win the
afces just because
miami is legit and you never know new
england
and the the way their salary cap is set
up and where that goes i think they'll
still be a player in this thing this
year
the jets i think right now are clearly
the least of the four teams in the afc
so yeah i'll go with the bills don't win
the asc east even though i think they
will
uh but it's just for this exercise i
think the jets do finish last
yeah i agree with you as well that
they're on the right track with robert
sala but it's not something that you
immediately see the jets
turning it around and becoming a team
that's going to contend
in a division that has some pretty good
teams between the dolphins the bills
and the pa the patriots are still the
patriots i mean with that crap roster
they still went seven and nine that's
right so they make some improvements
they've got the cap space to go out and
chase some free agents they could be a
lot better
in 2021 what's more likely washington
repeats as the nfc
east champion or the nfc east winner
gets 10 plus wins i guess this is one
where we could say both
you you could say both um
ten plus wins in this division the way
they're set up right now
i it was a weird year i gotta think one
of the i'm gonna
go when the nfc east winner gets 10 plus
wins i don't know who that's going to be
i'm not gonna just say washington
repeats
they were it was very close this year
they were even a little fortunate down
the stretch
so i i i'm gonna go the nfc east winner
gets ten plus wins i just don't know
who that's gonna be i really don't
that's the odd thing
yeah and you saw the cowboys there as
the favorites in the division at -125
and washington despite
winning the division man they are in
dead last in the odds at plus 800 for
the nfc east all right
what's more likely the packers run away
with the nfc north
again or the vikings
true to form get back to the playoffs
odd year playoffs even year no players
odd year playoffs that's right we love
him
we love him not we love him this year
okay good all right that's where we are
i think if you're gonna still give me my
option there
i'm still gonna go with green bay
running away with a division
i am like minnesota certainly could see
them right there in the playoff hunt a
lot like we saw last year
yeah i just i think green bay is clearly
the best team in that division right now
with chicago
and the quarterback issues detroit their
new reconstruction
reconstruction of the organization and
things like that i'm gonna go with green
bay one runs away
with the nfc north again i agree with
you as well the thing that really stands
out
to me detroit at plus 2700
points bet not a big believer in the
kneecap biting lions
for 2021 and jared goff and everything
that goes along with it and look at that
for good reason i whatever the lions
have
cooking the meal ain't going to be ready
in 2021
i am comfortable putting myself out
there saying that
despite what could happen on the old
takes exposed twitter account with that
with that take
i i am i am content in my belief that
we're not going to see the lions
win the nfc north in 2021. all right one
more real quickly what's more likely the
nfc
west winner gets the number one seed
or all four nfc west teams make the
playoffs i mean this one didn't
have i mean come on what are the chances
of all four teams making the playoffs in
the nfc west we like talking about it
but it's not going to happen
it's more likely the nfc west winner is
going to be the one seat i know but i
mean geez
it's so close this year it's not like
crazy with that division
it really isn't but i still think that i
would go with the other one as well that
the nfc west winner gets the number one
seed
you know but that's not going to be easy
there's no guarantees with any of this
either one of these ones for sure i mean
tampa bay of course we know green bay
and rogers gonna be damn good
and i'm still not throwing new orleans
out of there
well but that but that's the thing we
got to remember nfc
east the second place team whoever it is
may not be very good nfc north second
place team whoever it is may not be very
good
comes down to whether or not the saints
will be good enough to take one of the
three wild card berths from the four
teams
in the nfc west or the three teams that
don't win it so there is look
it's gonna happen eventually with those
three extra wild card spots at some
point
the planets are going to line up in a
way where all four teams from one
division make it to the playoffs it's
going to happen
it will happen at some point and i hope
i live long enough
to see it hi i'm mike tarico and thanks
for watching
make sure to hit subscribe for the
latest news and highlights
from nbc sports